sa rue
à
non mais non
elle a quelque chose là
ce matin
je venais
rami
des marins etc
molson
il a bien fini
françoise hardy
soir bonsoir c'est la vraie
je suis sûr que vous connaissez les
propos je vous embrasse pour mon fils et
mon mari qui vous adore et moi je suis
toujours oui tu vas gentil c'est kad et
olivier
quel talent françois je suis sûr vous
n'êtes pas du tout contente des chansons
que j'ai choisi a quand même y en avait
2 3 qui sait que la première en tous les
cas vous n'avez pas du tout mais les
autres ça va je suis un petit peu
fatigué et c'est normal oui comment ça
va ça va vous avez l'air free devant
voit un moi aussi je très heureux de
vous voir sérieusement
alors vous avez vous êtes très critique
sur vos premiers ne voulait réécouter
jamais parlé si on est dernier aussi en
tout cas il ya une chanson de vous qui
sort actuellement et qu'on écoutera
encore dans dix ans dans les émissions
de télévision
magnéto ch